What you call exile
for 1 rule of law,
here and anywhere in the world is to flee
of justice.
When you talk about us proposing amnesty,
the only possible answer
is that this is not poseable in 1 state
democratic constitutional,
because it would be to suppress
continues
1 of the 3 branches of government,
which is the judicial branch.
That you don't like,
that does not seem right to you
who are trying to break the Constitution,
that are committed
crimes as of September.
Exactly what we have experienced,
do not repeat,
but they can repeat it
because the fullness of Spanish democracy
allows it.
You allowed it this afternoon,
here
and I have been able to hear it